♪ ♪ ♪
Le centre Arsenal  le quartier
Petite-Bourgogne à Montréal,
est composé de trois grandes
salles. Et dans chacune d'elles,
exposition qui vaut le détour.
D'une part, l'exposition
immersive "Imagine Monet",
présentée en primeur mondiale.
exposition Imagine Monet- Monet,
le père de l'impressionisme,
mais c'eersion. Il a peint
des toiles... La fin de sa vie
est consacrée pour un musée
rie, qu'il a construit,
vraiment, comme un espace
immersif. Il souhaitait queit ié
dans ses toiles.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Les visiteurs peuvent
déambuler entourés
géants, où plus de 200 tableaux
du maître sont projetés.'il a cs
toiles pour l'Orangerie,
on est au début des années 20.
La France et l'Europe viennent
précédent. C'est la Première
Guerre mondiale. C'est un li
de sérénité. C'est un lieu dans
lequel on peut s'immerger de
qu'après les deux années que
nous venons de traverser,
de restituer ce message.
- Arsenal accueillt
Elektra, la 5e Biennale
internationale d'art numérique.
le Japon, la Chine et la Corée
sont à l'honneurthèmethèmethèmee
"Métamorphosis", l'exposition
est une invitation à réfléchirus
grandissie
dans nos vies.
ALAIN THgén., Bigén., Bigén., Be
- On vit dans une ère assez
la fois que certaines personnes
peuvent trouver inquiétante,
avec tout le développement
technolol'on vit
présentement. Et puis, le monde
de l'art est un reflet de ça
♪ ♪ ♪
- Finalement, dans la salle
centrale, l'exposition "Jardin
au milieu de l'hiver.
On y présente 23 oeuvres
d'artistes locaux et
récentes. C'est une réflexion
sur ce confinement
forcé à chercher à l'intérieur
l'imagination durant le temps
du confiors,ors,ors,ors,ors,ors,
maintenant qu'on peut retourner
s'en priver?
Ici Nab,
Radio-Canada, Mon